Howdy, howdy, howdy, howdy, howdy, howdy, howdy, howdy.
You don't like heights?
Well, that's awkward.
Because I just signed this lease for 10 years.
water oh my gosh wait i forgot water
i'll be right back i'm going downstairs
holy cow that's scary you fall down and then you fall up
even whoa are you guys a stove ever smelled like wet dog
apparently that's a problem sometimes with glass stove tops
i would walk would smell something so gross in the mid-cafe
kitchen and I would be like, what is that smell?
And I thought it was my sink.
And then one day I smelled my stove and it smelled like wet
dog.
And then I, I was like, why does my, I googled, why does my
stove smell?
And then there were so many other posts being like, my, my
stove smells like wet dog.
And I cleaned it.
with baking soda and vinegar.
And now it's fine.
YIVI!
What have you been cooking?
Spinach and mac and cheese.
Hello from Columbus where I'm at work because the power is
out at home until Friday.
Storm's so bad it flipped the car.
Oh my gosh, Nicholas, be safe.
Into my family.
I found out today that Nikki from Obsession is gonna be Waka
about character this year's Halloween.
How are you feeling about this?
Wait, that's kind of awesome, no?
Possessed Nikki.
Yes.
But I find her scariest when she like isn't doing anything.
Does that make sense?
When she's like standing in corners and staring at me.
Hmm.
I think that's best.
Hey, Minto, you were the best, cutest ghost.
I should, I'll thank you for 15 months.
Hi, guys.
We're doing karaoke today.
I don't feel like you love me as much as I do.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Miko, happy birthday.
Happy, happy birthday.
Happy birthday.
I wish I was at Comic-Cat August instead of December.
Oh, Comic-Cat December will also be so great.
What are you talking about?
It'll also be so great.
Turning 31 is not that bad.
Wait, shall we start with a warm-up, everybody?
I think we know what we start almost every single karaoke
with nowadays.
Wait, I can never remember which one though it is.
What's this one?
I'll just sing this one.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday to you Happy birthday
to you Happy birthday to you Happy birthday to you Happy
birthday to you Happy birthday to you Happy birthday to you
Delicious That is for everybody whose birthday it is today
Happy birthday to you
Yes Is there a mix and call for this now?
There's a mix and call for literally anything As long as you
put your mind to it As long as you put your mind to it It
also happens to be Shota-Aoi's birthday today!
Aurebo!
Thank you once again for enlightening me on the character's
birthdays.
Thank you.
Or people's birthdays.
You've done Sayu before, I'm pretty sure, too.
Min-to-Kyoto!
My birthday is the same day as Skyline Serenade.
I'll be cheering you all on from home.
Say-see-ya!
Happy early birthday!
I'm sorry I missed it.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
birthday happy birthday chat here's a free super for your
birthday but that's going to me so
how do you mean though still looking um work oh still
working on my ghost shrine got any advice on organizing
acrylic standies to look pretty i'll have your beautiful
singing in the background while organizing things you know
if it's not hi
recently after I moved to maid cafes where I said, oh no, I
think I have too many acrylic standees.
And they are all just out.
Kotaku.
Thank you so much for the pop gift.
Still trying to figure out what I'll be doing before the
concert and after next week.
Mostly along the lines of food choices.
And there are a lot of options.
Oh yes.
Yes.
You never have too many acrylics.
I agree because I'm about to go to Comic-Cat and get more.
And I'm a little worried for myself.
DuckDuck, welcome back!
Kabo!
Thank you for the vibe gifted!
It's okay, I love seeing you get to do super cool stuff.
I see it as a win.
Thank you guys for the birthday wishes.
Yeah!
No!
one thing okay we're me okay so right before the stream
actually the trivia stream nimi phoebe and i were talking we
were like obviously kiki will be there too but we were like
what are some things that we can do during the weekend um
for while we're in new york we're kind of stuck between the
zoo i think it's the bronx zoo we're stuck between that
we're stuck between in the Botanical Gardens, because right
now the Botanical Gardens has a Moomin collab!
A Moomin collab!
We're stuck between that.
We're stuck between a Broadway show.
So, yeah.
Do you have a happy anniversary song?
It's number 36 for me and Teal Orca, if not a happy
anniversary song.
Happy anniversary to you.
Happy anniversary to you Happy anniversary Happy anniversary
to you Happy Tenton again Happy anniversary to you and Tila
Rika Wait, number 36?
Like, years?
Choice seems kind of obvious if Moomin's there.
I know, but just because I love Moomin's, It doesn't mean
everybody else loves movement, but I really want to go to
the moon with botanical gardens.
Tom, oh my gosh, that is exactly why.
Okay, so I'm just going to read your super chat first.
Listen to me, you have to go to the Bronx Zoo.
It's my favorite place on planet Earth, and they have a baby
reptile nursery for you to look at.
I know, I know.
That's exactly why I've been told to go to the zoo.
So I'm absolutely torn.
Absolutely torn.
We'll figure out what we're going to do.
And once we do, we'll tell you all about it.
Tell you all about it.
Can't go to both.
Unfortunately, probably not.
I don't know.
We'll see.
I think we can choose two things, but definitely not three
things, unfortunately.
That's okay, that's okay, that's okay, that's okay.
I work at the Bronx Zoo, pretty great place.
Used to have a zipline area too, but it's not there anymore
sadly.
No!
Wait, that's so a zipline!
I feel like you're just here for the zipline.
Just stay an extra day with stopping you?
No, it's okay.
I already have my ticket booked.
I don't want to stay an extra day.
To be honest.
And I would have to extend my hotel.
And all of that.
Oh.
The intrepid aircraft carrier is also cool.
But I don't know if ghosts can appear on aircraft carriers.
Is that far?
No, stop giving me more things that I want to do.
If you bring one of your snake figures with you, you can see
the snakes.
do it for his own enrichment he already saw federal hall 28
months let's go take any socks shucks guess you'll have to
come back another time oh shoot i guess i have to go back to
new york intrepid was cool yeah man guess you know guess
we'll have to have another show there huh i guess so well
shoot I probably, since this is a karaoke stream, I should
at least sing some songs.
Today's songs are Anything Goes, but not that song from
Indiana Jones.
I do have some, I do have some summer songs.
I think this will be my last karaoke before end of summer,
so...
it's really just singing whatever i want probably a lot of
idol songs to be honest i've been a very idly mood so i
actually you can't see it but i do have joy sound on my
switch pulled up so um yeah have you ever had a chopped
cheese before chopped cheese i can't say i've been to new
york so many times can't catch the whole stream this month
is super concert heavy but i wanted to wish you the best in
NYC.
I'll see you there.
See you there.
Quick, what is the capital of New York State?
It's New York!
New York!
Yeah.
They're possibly going to Broadway.
Maybe some musicals.
Wait, that's a good idea, no?
Hope you have fun and stay hydrated at Comic-Cat.
I know I will, and I am in minto water.
With the Ayami Minto water for only 250 yen.
Yes, yes!
Eating who's...
Eating what?
Welcome back, thank you.
Albany, I've never heard of her.
Sounds nice.
I just finished Simple Gear earlier this month and I've been
on Idol Kick too.
Have you heard of it?
Of course I've heard of it.
I've heard of course I've heard of Simple Gear.
I live in the capital region of New York.
You may as well ban me now.
Why are we banning you?
She lives upstate.
Yeah, upstate.
Helena by MCR.
I'm not necessarily taking requests, but I will listen to
requests and maybe do them.
But thank you, Alex.
Albany?
Why would I ban Y?
I'll ban Y!
I'll ban ye.
I'll ban...
I'm going to ban ye!
No!
I'll ban...
I ban ye.
I ban ye, too.
100 days...
Of your stove smelling like wet dog.
Shremwise!
Happy birthday!
Would love to hear lingering summer tonight.
That one I already had on my list.
Oh.
the horror.
Hundred days of your stove smelling back.
It's not even... Like, it's such a strange phenomenon.
You walk past and it's just like a lingering whiff.
A lingering summer.
Lingering summer.
No, it's just like a little whiff of it.
Like, sometimes you don't even smell it.
It was driving me insane.
I was actually going bonkers being like, what is the smell?
But apparently, it's a thing with with uh what's the word
glass stovetops sometimes and one of my cleaners that I was
cleaning it with was making it worse isn't that the worst
thing ever oh my gosh
uh gross I know it's a betrayal for real love Minky love I
love singing, love Mickey's singing.
Thank you!
Uramishi Kiyun Dog, Kiyun Dog.
Kiyun Dog?
Kiyun Dog.
Kiyun Dog, Kiyun Dog.
I feel like I wanna warm up with something.
The east side of Manhattan has lots of Japanese jazz bars.
Definitely recommend checking them out.
jazz is my favorite but it got too popular oh no it's like
always the the dilemma right where you're like i must
gatekeep because i want to enjoy this for my i want to
continue to enjoy this at a leisurely way but then at the
same time i want their business to succeed so i want them to
be successful and get lots of business.
Hello, Minto!
I look forward to Skyline Saturday next week.
I'm glad I caught a karaoke.
Idol songs or whatever you feel like sounds like a gift.
Caveman, thank you!
I should visit Federal Hall for MGS2.
You should!
You should.
Hi, Minto.
Hello!
You know what?
I wasn't going to turn on the air, but I will.
I'm going to sing a song.
This is an oldie but a goodie.
It's been, um, it's, it's been a while since I've sung this
song, so I might mess it up.
Actually, do I still have the, the, the, the karaoke of it?
Okay, I don't know if I do.
Um, uh, I don't know.
Maybe I don't.
Wait, what's so funny?
Oh, I could sing it on!
I could sing it on.
What's the word?
Joy sound.
Apropos of nothing.
But you're saying wet dog.
Sometimes I'll mix Diet Dr. Pepper and Peanut Butter
Whiskey.
I call it a wet dog.
Does it smell like wet dog?
You know when sometimes after it rains, you go outside and
it smells like a wet dog?
Can you sing the door opening?
That one was the hardest one for me.
It's been so long since I've heard that one.
No way, I don't think I kept it instrumental.
this was i stupid maybe it might be stupid oh my gosh wait
that's crazy hold on hold on i'm gonna look this i'm gonna
look wait actually wait maybe i might be in another place
hmm maybe i just sing the original key though it's a little
it's a little low for me
This one's a warm-up.
For real.
Because it's going to get my...
It's going to get my lips loose.
Okay, maybe I'm fine.
Maybe I'm okay.
Wait, I'm going to test and make sure it's not too low for
me.
It's fine.
Whatever.
We just do it.
We're just on this Ferris wheel of karaoke for fun.
Right.
Yeah,
we do it live.
We do it live.
Yeah!
All our love, However weakly and darkened, like the rain of
the rain, the rain will haplow.
Our friends' eyes are small, get in the hands of the hands.
Enriching friends, friends and family, give your family a
chance to
be.
Renewable for such a place.
With the most enjoyable little courage and a small pride and
a big hope to the middle of your life, and you'll be happy
for those things
That was a
babies my favorite monkey monkey baby song i sing it every
time
tipokina yuki
yeah tipokina yuki monkey monkey baby songs are always so
there's also like they're all so like yeah you can do it you
can do it Perfect warm-up.
It was a little low for me, but that's okay.
That's okay.
Let's see.
You sounded good?
Glad I could catch you, catch me before your trip.
Hey!
Stop spoiling stuff.
You don't even...
What the heck?
How are you guys, like, psychic sometimes?
I don't understand.
How are you guys psychic sometimes?
I haven't sung that song in so long.
And then the other day I was like, oh, can't you catch me?
What the heck?
That's actually scary to me.
Me too, I bought a...
I thought you said a horse.
We sing congratulations!
Just finished moving, thanks to the karaoke!
Congratulations!
I boo our knowers, truly!
Okay, we'll sing, this is not a summer song at all, but I
love this song anyway.
cause cause cause cause Frame Tail Cause Catch u Catch u Cat
Train Weldanger
I love
each time
thank you so much for the vibe get it thank you thank you
loving the kazoo solos thank you thank you kazoo kun
just like that
no i still have my omni cord oh my gosh i do actually i was
just thinking oh my gosh stop my head.
Sayage, thank you so much for the thank you.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, literally.
Yesterday?
Day before yesterday?
Stop.
I was like, oh, I want to do another Omnicord stream soon.
I should get a couple of songs that I can learn really well
and then play those.
And then I was also looking up the new Omnicord.
How did you know?
Literally, like yesterday I was looking up if I could get
the new Omnicord.
How?
Minto singing stream just as I'm settling in for dinner.
What a fantastic surprise.
Have a good dinner.
I shall bless your meal.
Oh, now it's delicious.
Yes.
Moe, moe, boo.
let's see hmm I'm not only going to sing Japanese songs
today but it might be a majority on accident just because I
don't know like I said lots of idle idle stuff on the brain
wait uh
hmm hmm
hmm I was living your head rent free truly though actually
actually actually Tascado
Adrian welcome to membership thank you so so much thank you
thank you thank you you know I'm not hot dog do have a safe
flight tomorrow when though excited to hear some karaoke and
we'll miss you dearly ah thank you thank you thank you Oh my
gosh, someone block.
Mods!
Mods, get denser to EXE channel.
They're hacked.
You know how you say you're in our walls?
Well, the feeling is mutual.
It must be when I'm possessing you guys.
That's kind of crazy.
It must be when I'm possessing you guys that sometimes my
thoughts go into your brain as well.
That's kind of terrifying.
Um, I know what I want to say next, but I think I actually
have to switch over to...
Let's see.
Is this still connected?
Oh no, okay.
Hold on.
I'll let you hear, uh...
Uh...
You can hear the lovely...
Um...
Joy sound music?
What was I searching?
I clicked the wrong thing.
Um, let's see.
I've been thinking about this song often recently.
That's why I sometimes think about Koharu.
It should be more than sometimes, I think, right?
do they have it
if they don't that's okay wait actually i don't think they
do no the song that i have been thinking of no the song that
i've been thinking of they do not have
it's that one kiari pamiu pamiu song Goodbye, teacher, my
friend.
Meow,
meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Unless I missed it.
I don't know.
I feel like they should have it, but whatever.
It's fine.
Maddie, sorry.
I'm not really taking...
You can...
I'm not really taking requests.
But I also don't know it.
I'm so sorry.
I've watched...
I watched Horimiya and I don't remember the ending.
I'm so sorry.
Happy for Minto karaoke and my birthday!
Hey, sorry!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Oh, wait!
I know a song I want to sing.
Wait.
I might really screw this up.
It's okay, though.
I might...
There's some fast parts in this.
But I don't care right now.
No, I just want to sing it.
We love the screw-ups.
Just meow, meow through the screw-ups.
Oh, wait.
Did I activate my pass?
No, I didn't.
Oops.
Whoopsie.
Hold on.
I got to activate my pass in the e-shop.
Oh.
Nintendo?
this is my japanese account wait huh
will you do 24 hour karaoke while you're gone not this time
I need my computer to to rest a little wait what
hold on I'm signing into my Nintendo account oh there we go
what is my white is my password I don't remember wait that
might be fine guys what's my password what's my password
I'll do forgot my password hold on whoops whoopsie oh I
should have set this up before stream bad oh
Snake butt 310.
You're so close.
Oh,
no.
Wait, nickname.
Submit.
Okay, okay, okay.
My new password is snake butt 310, doll.
Okay, okay.
Now let me in.
Let me in.
Snake butt three.
Oh.
I did 311 on accident.
Email verification.
Oh.
I'm on my phone.
Figuring this out.
Pat?
No, let me in.
Oh, it signed me in.
You do not have permission to access this information.
Huh?
On this Nintendo account?
What are we talking about?
Ah!
Oh, wait.
Maybe I got it.
I think I got it.
Let me sing.
Yippee!
Okay, we're good.
Wait, what song was I about to sing?
I can't even remember.
Oh, sorry.
I think you can see.
the bottom.
There we go.
I hit it.
Let me sing!
I thought they region locked it for a second.
Oh!
I remember what I'm singing.
Hopefully the music video doesn't make me laugh.
Like it usually does.
Oh no,
no, no,
no your love love will be will be oh you
you paradox the you ticked oops
the paradox The most high-predoxed, happiness is the the
most-predoxed the most-predoxed the most-predoxed,
see-pred-predoxed, the most-predoxed the most-predoxed, the
most the most-predoxed That was
That was Psy-Joh-C-P-P-A-Docs Psy-J-C-P-P-P-A-Docs
Miao, miao, miao, miao, miao.
That's by Wasita!
Wasita is like an iconic...
You know, before...
Before...
Before, like, Fruit Zipper, and those groups got really
popular, and their kind of goal was Harajuku to all over the
world!
We had Wasita!
And Wasita, the world standard, that's their idol group
name, is...
They were...
They were the group that were Harajuku to all over the
world.
they they they were that those girls and unfortunately they
disband next year or is it later this year regardless
they're disbanding unfortunately so yeah hey thank you i
hope you're having a wonderful day the same way you make our
days wonderful with your beautiful sing singing even if i
meow meow even if i meow meow
You follow them.
Yeah, their group is, they have really fun songs.
That one was actually for Puri Parada.
That's why at the end.
Dabu, Puri Parada, that part.
Hey, Minto.
Thank you for the excellent karaoke stream.
I just wanted to wish you all the best on your trip and
performance.
Hope you have a great time at Comic-Cat and in New York.
Safe travels.
Dredna, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Let's see.
What else?
Wait.
I think I know what I want to sing.
Especially if you meow meow.
But they have to have this song.
Yeah.
This is like the song.
This is the song First time hearing me sing You have high
expectations?
Okay.
Hopefully I won't let you down.
This song is by Nana Mizuki Doso.
Please don't judge too hard.
Can we get a Triangle Dreamer Meow Meow version?
Maybe.
Oh my gosh.
There was a...
So many of the Nijikon songs are so fast.
So hard for me to sing them.
Oh, hi, Kira!
Especially if I'm meow, meow.
Hopefully I can be super sexy for this next song.
Oh, gosh.
Death the Gordy.
Thank you for the 50.
Mm-hmm.
Hello?
Let's go, lady, let's go, lady Deep emotion, deep emotion
Sweetie darling, let's go, let's go, let's go Hatchikere,
beauty lady
Oh my gosh, the timing is off from the day of the days.
I love you so much.
I want to be so excited in my heart and my eyes are in my
eyes.
Oh, I'm so happy to be here.
I love you so much love you.
I love you so much so love you.
My darling, hey baby, now let's go and make sure.
I love you sexy beauty.
It's a new life, a sweet, sweet dream.
My love, see, the world will change
Choo-l-choo-l-choo-choo-choo-paya Sexy, oh, sexy feeling
Choo-choo-choo-choo Dramatic, ah-choo-choo Dramatic,
deja-vue Me-tou-took-took-took-took Colorful, sweety story
The heart is deeply Kizami-combe When the small The small
darkness When the light comes When the light comes When the
light is light If it's so, It's always the The infinite sky
The stars' The stars' The stars are The stars That's why
Happy Station Mezzar The Chimaygo Fifteen, Fifteen, A-15
100% more than 100% of the love I'm here to be here I'm here
to help you Chiru, chiru, chiru, chiru, pavetina
Dibu, I want you to be there, I want you to be happy to be
here
My darling
Ah, there's so much katakana in that song.
I can't read it so fast.
Disco-tick.
The more I'm learning Japanese, the more I dislike Katakana.
No, you can't dislike it.
to just embrace it.
Can confirm what's sexy?
Let's go.
What's another...
I know a lot of people like when I sing Lower Register.
What's another lower...
Wait!
I know, I know one.
I know one.
I think I have to get rid of a... Hold on, wait.
I have to pull up the lyrics for this.
It's been a minute, though, since I've sung this.
This song too.
Karaoke.
Go away.
One second.
Let me double check this.
Okay, maybe this.
Sorry, can I mess it up a little bit?
If you are taking a request, can I request skip the
abadabaduba?
Oh, by Suise or he cannot board the light.
I'm not taking a request, bride.
I'm sorry.
But maybe, maybe I will sing them later.
I'd rather not.
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
Okay, I try to sing this.
I think these...
Hold on.
Wait, I have to restart.
I think these lyrics are wrong.
Hey.
I hope
I started at the right spot too.
I hope I started at the right spot too.
Before I get back to my life When I started that little girl
and my future If I'd stop it again to do it again When I
started that little girl and I'm a big hit I'd send a car to
another other day If I could do it again, do it again Oh Oh
I'm I'm You know But
Why I love you I've never One of the things I've never heard
about The love you gave me, two of us together I'm going to
sing my love, I'm going to sing those words I'll be able to
give a promise to us to sing our love.
I'm going to play around with that girl and my future If I'm
stuck in a car and I'm going to be able to hear it from you,
If you know that you're the one who's a victim So if you
look at me, I'll meet you again when you walk in the dark
Du-Lur-Lur-lu-Lur-Lur-lulur-l twitter-lur-lur-lu O Meaning
D-Lur-lur-lur, That's the fact that my future Is The Gemini
Doka That's the one And the one, The Doka, that's the one
I'm the에서 The other one, otoka-loka- As long as we walk down
the same time as well, you know, we can always be loved we
can always agree to live in the world.
We can always celebrate and it level in the same time as we
can always be loved in the world.
We can always truly Nordic,
Thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
You like my Odoriko.
Thank you, thank you.
RGF has died of...
Jazzy O'Neesan, Doki Doki...
Doki...
Like Doki Doki Centauri?
Doki Doki Centauri voice at Ferris wheel distancing.
One of my favorite places to do karaoke is a is in a Ferris
wheel, actually.
There is a Ferris wheel at Tokyo Dome City.
And you can do karaoke there.
Some of the...
Thank you, Nauuta, Deistita!
Thank you, thank you very much.
At the Tokyo Dome City Ferris wheel, you can do karaoke.
And, yes.
Always a treat when Minto sings some of my favorite songs.
Yeah, I'm glad you liked my Minto album and all of my...
Valerie, thank you!
sounds so idyllic yeah you can see you can see like Tokyo
Skytree you see Tokyo Dome obviously below you and at night
it's very nice it's very nice does it have free Ghana or
Romani at the Carey Commission on it does not but it has
many very popular songs or very popular yeah popular songs
and artists so I think if you were to
If you were to do it, you could like look it up while you're
singing, you know.
Maybe don't have a great holiday.
Thank you, Jumbo!
Thank you!
I want to sing AKB48.
What AKB48 song though?
Pia?
Oh!
Any song here?
Pia!
Wait, let me add you as a mod.
Peepie!
I'll see you soon.
Me too love.
See?
Take care before the search.
Thanks for making me smile every day.
Thank you!
I love Tokyo Don't Ferris wheel.
Yeah, it's so good.
Actually, it's so good.
Soon after all this time, you can still drop a song that
makes me say, Dang, she has a beautiful voice.
You're going to question it in New York.
Oh, do me.
my best don't do my best heavy rotation i feel like i always
sing heavy rotation though if only i were in 3d i would do
some of these uh i would do some of the dances wait i kind
of want to sing river but i sing that before it just does
not hit when it's solo
hmm shonichi
There's a new song that they have out called Suki Sh.
It's so cute, actually.
I quite like it a lot.
I'm looking through the songs right now.
Oh, here, hold on.
I'll let you listen to.
Suki.
Hold on,
Tee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-hoo.
Let's see.
Hold on, I'm going to take a voice thingy.
There's Uza.
That's like right when I started falling out of Aikibi.
So like, I don't know it so well.
Oh,
there's also first rabbit.
How's that called?
Heart got the virus!
Wait, that's perfect.
We also love Jujigatzen.
We'll do this in fall because it's called the anklet of
November.
Heart got a virus.
I know they have it somewhere.
It's probably...
Yes, I found it.
Heart's got the virus.
That's a good one.
That's a really good one.
Oh, so did I have to.
Where did you go?
I didn't know I'm afraid of love.
What was the only way I got the way back?
What was the way?
The way I didn't remember the way I didn't know When the
heart got down With us, it's like a
This song is like one of the most
Actually, this is a three-person song!
I wonder if I can get...
I wonder if I can get Densetsu to sing this with me.
It is, wait for like Valentine's Day.
It's so iconic.
Like if I look up, let's see.
Heartcutta virus.
Let's see.
If I look up like cover, I know.
It's so iconic.
This song.
Actually, I don't recognize anyone.
That's so funny.
But yeah, it's a very, it's a very, popular Ikibi song and
it's very cute because the girl who the center actually it
was all three of them were very popular it was what Koji
Haru and Matsui Dena and who was the last one
beginner in your position set sorry I'm still eating this
I'm still I should talk while I, before I finish my...
I should have talked while I was finishing my...
What's it called?
My cough drop.
Oopsie.
I was just singing with it.
I was like...
Yay!
Shadow Cross.
Thank you so much for the time get did!
Mint you have the most beautiful voice ever.
I've been broke, so that's why I haven't super chatted a
while.
Anything like?
Time to test!
No!
Yeah, never feel pressured to donate ever, ever, ever, ever,
ever, ever, ever, ever, ever, ever, ever, ever.
Ever!
No!
I hope you're doing okay.
We're doing welcome back.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Hmm.
Let's add more idle stuff.
Maybe Dempogumi.
Actually, I wonder.
I don't think they will, but I'm going to check if they have
a group that...
Wait.
I'm going to check if they have a group.
Oh.
If they do, I'm going to be really surprised, but they're...
Happy.
The vibes of the BGM and Ferris wheel are so nice.
Right!
That's so true.
Hmm.
I guess not.
I guess I don't.
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna make sure I'm spelling this right.
Den-den passion.
If you want me to die.
Yeah.
Wait, yeah.
I guess they don't.
That's so sad.
Oh, I like, oh, when you're in, when the idols you are in
two are too small and they don't appear in the program.
No, no.
My idols are too small.
No.
I'm already dead.
So true.
Let's see what other Dumpagumi we have on here, though, I
would like to sing Dempogumi Inc.
Departure!
Wait!
Can I sing this?
I don't know if I remember it.
Except...
Wait, they have a Sabikara!
They have just the chorus!
I'll try- wait.
I don't know if I remember this.
I'll do-do-do the Sabikara.
Oh my goodness.
Sing it like Mimi did.
Exactly.
This is just the chorus.
That's so funny.
I guess for popular anime songs that people don't know the
full version of, they just have the chorus.
Thank you.
That's actually it.
Wait!
Wait, hold on.
I think I could sing.
Wait.
I think I could sing it.
Wait, I'm gonna say I'm gonna try.
Departure.
Maybe.
I might forget some parts.
I might forget some parts, but whatever.
It's karaoke.
Who cares, right?
Who cares?
It's not even TV size.
I know, right?
Literally, Just the chorus.
It's always a good, it has a lot of meaning.
It's a lot of love.
Thank you.
You can smile again.
You can fly away.
The world is your own.
The world is waiting for you.
When you step back, you will wake up.
With the angel's smile, you'll be able to take it back.
Swah!
The beginning is always too late.
You'll never stop.
You'll
never stop.
You'll never give up.
You'll never stop.
You can try again, You can try again You can go Oh, you go
away Not you can, you just Oh, I'm waiting Aoe-sola,
Kake-nuke, Unabara, Goethe, Go ahead, the angel's nagging,
kiss, Take your breath.
Can't try!
I'm glad no one ever saw I've seen a lot of the world To
make sure that we're I'm on the ground, I'm on the ground,
and you're gonna wake up with the angel's smile.
See you live!
We're never gonna end, We're not gonna end the balla When
you leave forever If the tears
flow around me, my tears go back to the Painting Listen to
the wind and add the angel.
All right, get your release from the end Don't let the pain
go
You can try!
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That was departure.
Got me smiling.
One of my all-time favorite anime songs right after the
ending for Blue Exorcist.
Who's the ending for Blue Exorcist?
But yeah, honestly, I'll admit, I've never seen Hunter
Hunter before, but...
I'm sorry, Hunter X Hunter.
But that song is so...
Awesome!
You can smile!
Take off!
Watch it now.
And we're extremely loud and correct buzzer!
Wait, do I have that?
Nope.
Hunter X Hunter.
Hunter X Hunter X Hunter.
Hunter X Hunter X Hunter X Hunter X Hunter X Hunter X
Hunter.
Hunter X Hunter X Hunter X Hunter X Hunter X Hunter X Hunter
X Hunter X Hunter X Hunter X Hunter X Hunter X Hunter X
Hunter X Hunter X Hunter X.
That song gets me hype.
Actually, there's another song I want to sing in a similar
way.
I've done this song before.
I don't know if I've ever done Departure before.
I think I've always too scared of it because i was like i'm
gonna mess it up i don't know it blunter x blunter
everybody knows this one too wait i think i need to actually
key wait i think i actually do need to plus two we'll see
The next song is...
...this.
Oh, oh.
...
There's time to figure out where room is gonna be.
What's going on in the system?
It'll be in the dark, but uh,
But no.
I'll wait for tomorrow's day to bite me.
Millerchte!
Infrequent a dream no after nothing, nothing...
Ah, so I love you and love it.
I think I'm feeling like I'm going to feel like I'm going to
tell you
The key is still all for me but I'm trying.
and they're very convenient, they're all talking about it.
They're singing songs and they're listening to the song what
are you going to this city to pick up?
I'm expecting it, but it's just no matter what happens.
Yeah, I'm telling you!
Uncertainly no, I'm not gonna let you let you know what's
wrong.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I'll say it's not bad, I'll say it's
just your image But if you're so mean, it's a little bit of
a wavy But it's still, I'm sure you'll be able to do it all
my love I'm back with
that In the un-mendable dream, no No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
Oh, sorry guys, I'm all, I feel like I'm messing up every
song today, but that's okay.
Butterfly.
That's how it, that's how it's stylized, right?
Let me double check.
That's how it's stylized, right?
Yeah.
Mito just sang the opening of my childhood anime after
singing the opening of my number one anime pre-karyoke.
Let's go!
Okay, now actual Dempa Gumi Inker.
Dempa, Dempa.
When I searched the Den, it gave me departure, so I got
distracted.
Denpa.
Tempo Gumi.
Incidentally, August 1st is the day of the chosen children
visited the digital world for the first time.
We are so close!
You're right!
That was just the other day!
You're right, you're right!
Hmm...
Do I want to sing Orange Ream?
This song is a very important song to Tempo Gumi.
It's kind of emotional.
Sabotage!
We'll disabotage.
Then, parcher gummy ink.
No, because I did the parcher.
Main name.
Lisa cheese.
Hey, Todd.
Whoa, what's wrong with my eyes?
Oh, oh, what's happening?
Ah, here we go now.
Wait.
Taipur, fire, side.
Vibe, Vibe, Vibe, Vibe, Vibe, I can't stand it!
You know you planned it!
I'm gonna set it straight!
This water gate!
I can't
sabotage!
All of y'all, it's a sabotage Listen, all of y'all, it's a
sabotage Listen, all of y'all, it's a sabotage Listen, all
of y'all, it's a sabotage
You're scheming on a thing that's sabotage!
I fooled you I said I would sing I got you I got you
Oh I wasn't typing it I said I would sing idol song But it's
a beastie boys But actually that's the Dempagumi Inc.
version of Sabotage Sabotage Yeah I'll write that I'll write
that Dempagumi Dempagumi Ink Version.
Wait, we can do this.
There we go.
Dempagumi Ink Version.
I love Toad Metal, Voice Metal.
I hope you guys like that one.
I hope you like that one.
Technically counts.
You loved it!
Yubi!
Let's see.
Oh, hello?
I'm pressing down, but my thing is going...
Oh.
Oh, I wish you guys could have seen that.
That was so mysterious.
Uh-oh.
I hope my controller's not dying.
Something, something...
Stick drift or whatever.
I was pressing down.
But it was going to the right!
What should I sing?
The actual Dampokumi song.
Give a quarter and it's order small fries, big mint, Yubi,
Ilan.
Has it been
the first time?
English, this is the best.
So, this is
it.
WWE, the ending, no.
My favorite super-kawaii idol group, Beastie Boys.
Sorry, there's so many Dumpagumi songs that I love that it's
hard to pick one.
We, oh, could I do Precious Summer?
It's quite fast.
I'll try.
Who cares anymore, right?
Who cares anymore?
This is such a good part.
And it's summer song, so it works, right?
I did say today would be a little more summery.
Oh
Give me time to That was
so high Was it?
Yippee!
I love that song.
Yes.
You killed it?
Yeah, I need a second.
It's big.
Give me a second.
It's like how in Japan, when you go to karaoke, they give
you like a calorie counter.
they give this hit here, you know.
Thank you for blessing me with wonderful karaoke, but for my
job interview tomorrow!
Kuyo!
Good luck you got this!
You got this!
Wait, can I sing a song that I haven't sung before?
In karaoke?
Ever, ever?
Wait, let me find the lyrics for it.
Wait, hold on.
Some people might know this song.
Some people might be excited for it.
It is a...
It is a, what's the word?
A summer song.
Oh.
I remember when you sang this song during Dampagumi and
Karaoke and you improved so much.
God, that happened.
Thank you.
World premiere.
Oh, geez.
That makes me nervous.
I'll do my best.
Let me make sure you can...
Let me...
This should be okay.
It's a very groovy song, so I think you guys will like it
too.
I'll do my best.
I should get some more water after this, though.
After this, tell me not to sing another song until I get
more water, okay?
Groovy, very groovy.
I've been thinking about you.
Crazy how the time goes passing by
Yes, these words to you I feel our time is coming soon With
what is left I don't
know what just happened Not bad One more time
About you Crazy how Oh, the time goes passing by Can I
confess these words to you?
I feel our time is coming soon With what is left, I'll sing
for you Oh, did you look above?
Heaven knows I'm dreaming of the one I love Oh, you know I
can't get enough I just wanna be the one who calls you, baby
Trace me so I'll find my way to you No one knows you, I need
you like you do Cannot confess these words to you I fear a
time is coming soon This love that's left belongs to you to
you somewhere in the stars are faded nothing on earth could
keep me waiting from searching for you and all that I do
didn't you look above heaven knows I'm dreaming of the one I
love oh you know I can't get enough oh I just want to be Oh,
I'm clicking on it.
I'm clicking on the player and that's what's causing it to
pause.
It's never done that before.
One, one more time.
One more time.
Take three.
Sorry.
Again, again.
.
soon with what is left i'll sing for you oh did you look
above heaven knows i'm dreaming of the one i love oh
yeah trace me so i'll find my way to you i fear our time is
coming soon oh wait i said the wrong line sorry Cannot
confess these words to you I fear a time is coming soon This
love that's left belongs to you Somewhere in the stars are
faded Nothing on earth could keep me waiting From searching
for you And all that I do that you look above heaven knows
I'm dreaming of the one I love oh you know I can't get
enough I just wanna be the one who calls you baby
yes that was from Stellar Blade Oasis?
I guess is what it's called?
Lately I've been thinking of about you what a funky song you
can see why you chose it three times baby i'm sorry i'm
sorry okay let me go get some water real quick here i'll
i'll put on some bgm for you guys while i yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i'm also gonna go to the little ghosty's room so
guys i'm actually excited for my trip this time maybe
because it's been a long time so since I've been able to go
to Japan that isn't a work fully work trip so I'm excited
I'm excited oh thank you look back thank you I'm back I'm
back just a few work things but not very many so I but the
weather looks a bit abysmal.
The weather looks absolutely horrible.
Nisharo-D!
Thank you for the supercharge.
Vivi Korn, thank you for the fine gilded!
Ah, no!
Thank you for the- Oh, that's so bad.
I had a nice, bittersweet dream, and I don't know why I was
in a bad mood all day.
Thank you so much for lifting me up and make all worries
disappear like you always do.
I'll be having a nice trip.
I'll be enjoying it.
You deserve it.
This is for you.
Thank you.
Sorry, you had a bad dream.
I had a freaky dream.
I had a dream that it was legends anew.
It was legends anew.
And, um, but it was inside like a community theater.
Like in, in America, sometimes like there's like plazas,
like a plaza of stores.
And sometimes there will be like community theaters in there
and stuff like I don't know and ours was at one like that
and like so there were people like like right next door was
a grocery store and so there would be kids walking by being
like mommy I want to go see the anime the cartoon characters
the mom would be like don't look okay me though I found this
weird stick on the ground I was also thinking I should make
a wish!
What do you think?
Wish for lots of ice cream.
Oh, I want ice cream now.
It's hot!
I want ice cream.
Thank you, thank you!
Tavo, thank you!
Thanks for the first real karaoke, Minto.
Of course!
We still have- I still want to sing more.
I still want to sing more.
What kind of ice cream?
Wow, Barry.
But yeah, it's like one of those Japanese Department Idol
shows.
Kind of.
It felt like that.
And at the same time, too, after the show, no, before the
show, the show hadn't started yet, they were giving
backstage tours to, like, you guys.
And so Vicky, Phoebe, and I were, like, Scooby-Dooing from
room to room to not be seen.
We were like, stop.
Stop!
This Supa is not for mint- it's to bribe the germs to make
sure they don't get her sick during your trip.
Oh, thank you!
Thank you!
It was so goofy.
Holy!
Oh my gosh!
Wow!
That's a really, really- Wow!
That's a- whoa!
My goodness!
That's a really big Akka Supa!
Thank you so much!
to the vtuber world but I've been joining you there's
streams a lot thank you for the entertaining streams keep
the good look good good good work well thank you so much
holy moly thank you how a wonderful true me though thank you
so much I hope you didn't feel like you had to donate that
amount but if you're new to the vtuber world you can always
just enjoy the streams never feel like you have to donate.
Never feel like you have to donate.
You can just come and vibe.
It's all good.
You don't even have to chat.
Thank you for the care.
You're keeping those safe travels.
Enjoy your trip.
Thank you.
Nami.
But we're not done yet.
We're not done yet.
I still want to sing so much more.
Wowie.
That was a lot.
Thank you!
Breaking out my Teru-Teru-Bozu.
Please, oh my gosh.
The weather in Tokyo looks so bad.
It's gonna, I think it's gonna be pouring and thundering and
storming throughout Comiket weekend.
Unfortunately.
Audio, don't go, you almost scared me.
I thought I was on mute this entire time.
Storms can be kind of romantic.
I'm scared of thunder.
I'm scared.
Yeah, keep the dojinchi dry.
Yeah, I'm nervous.
At least it won't be that hot.
No, it's also going to be hot while it's storming.
It's going to be hot while it's storming.
Let's see.
Right?
Well, I guess it's actually not that bad while it's
storming.
95% humidity is kind of insane.
Oh wait!
It looks like...
Wait, it looks like it's kind of clearing up.
It looks like not thunderstorms anymore, but maybe just
rain.
Wait, that would be great!
I really feel for all the people that will have to like...
I mean, me too though.
I'm gonna be also lining up outside.
Flood!
Happy birthday!
Last Saturday, I'm so sorry I missed it!
Happy, happy birthday!
Weather looks bad and I was planning to do Fuji on Sunday.
Oh no!
Yeah, Sunday looks like it's cloudy, rainy.
Oh, no.
Bring a cute umbrella.
I have a normal umbrella.
I need a strong umbrella, I think.
It'll be fine.
Please go and have fun.
Yeah, I'll try.
All right, Will.
I think I'll have fun, I hope.
Ayami can't sneak you in early.
It's not about that.
Well, I mean, she did get me...
I did get my ticket from Ayami Mama.
Thank goodness.
My savior.
But, um...
But...
Uh...
You know, I'm still gonna be lining up, you know?
I'm just like every other otaku.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I went...
I got tired of umbrellas and went back to rain ponchos.
I wonder if a rain poncho would be better.
Because...
But then it would be...
I don't know.
It's gonna be so sad.
smelly.
I could just, I could just, it's going to smell like, like
wet people and sweat.
It's going to be, it's going to be so sweaty and wet because
of all the humidity and the heat and all the people and it's
going to, oh, it's going to, oh.
Have a blast.
I haven't been since movie Comey in 2018.
I want to go back to Comey Kids so bad.
I hope you can.
2018, that's a long time ago.
That's, I hate to tell you, but that's almost, that's almost
10 years ago.
The wet dogs.
Not the wet dogs.
Sometimes outside after a rain it does smell like wet dog.
It does sometimes.
It does.
Please stay hydrated.
I will.
Thank you.
The name of the songs?
The name of the songs are on the screen.
Under set list.
I do write them.
I write them after I sing them.
Yeah.
So if you heard a song that you like...
I'm confused.
Zoinks, Phoebs, jankies, Vicky.
Now let's see who's under that Ibu mask.
Steiner!
What?
Just like every other otaku on all the merch.
You.
Wait, I'm on the merch.
I know but it's it's I'm still I'm still just an otaku to be
honest
I'm not I'm not any different from you guys I think say
travels me don't have a great time at climate kit I hope you
survive the weather slash humidity ps6 super excited to see
you at skylight serenade afterwards yes I'll see you there
my skin sanity I wish it smelled like me into outside when
it rains honestly petition petition to just have giant air
fresheners blowing mint smell Are you an Otaku too?
Explodes because of the lawyerer video.
Let's see guys.
What do we want to sing?
It's karaoke.
Karaoke.
Oh, fun that.
Why is this not loading?
Hmm.
Carry on my wayward, son.
Yum, yum, yum.
Ah, gosh.
Holy loud.
Oh my gosh.
We're good at it.
Thank you.
Thanks for making us stinky dinosaurs.
Have a great trip.
See you in New York.
Thank you.
Thank you for the pink don't know.
Let's see.
Take me to love.
I hope you have so, so, so much fun living.
I don't live anything.
All your otaku dreams and I can't wait to see you.
Live in my home state.
York.
That's what everyone calls it.
Wait, go for your new Yorker.
York.
Wait, I think I know what I want to sing.
Probably nobody.
I don't want to say nobody.
Probably very few people might know this artist.
that's okay I
like her songs well actually let's see what they have of
hers
yeah I'll sing this one wait hold on a second Gramulize
thank you welcome the membership welcome welcome welcome
la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la um okay I
sang this song once at karaoke.
My friends were like, you're into some weird music.
I was like, who?
Well, actually, maybe it's not even this one.
That's the weird one.
Maybe I didn't sing this one at karaoke.
Hold on.
Let's see.
Wait, wait.
Did I have it?
I...
Maybe they don't.
Unless it's in...
Maybe I'm reading it wrong.
Weird is good.
Yeah, I think weird is fine, right?
Um...
Do they really not have it?
Oh, they do have it!
Okay, I'll sing this one.
instead.
Or I could sing both.
Who cares?
Whatever.
Anyway.
Dogma maguma.
The singer is Omori Seiko.
She's a bit controversial, but I still like her music.
Meow.
Where is it gonna start?
Is it gonna start?
Hello.
Oh!
That's why I didn't start!
You guys can't hear it!
Wait a second, one second.
Cancel.
Or, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just realized I didn't have a...
There we go, there we go, there we go, there we go.
Okay, I was like, hello?
This is... This is taking forever!
Okay, there we go.
Okay, now one more time!
The song is silent.
That's why it's so weird.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hey, is it a god?
Thank you.
I love you I
mean I mean I don't know Amen God's name Amen Amen
Such a funny song That was it Dogma Magma Dogma Magma
Never heard it before It's amazing I feel like the original
Definitely is much better It's one of those songs that It's
fun to sing but I'm singing to...
To...
It's just to sing because I like the song.
It's not like a... Oh, this is gonna sound like a perfect...
A perfect cover or anything?
Let's see.
You're so full of energy!
Yippee!
What do I want to sing?
No, I'll save this one.
Well, it's also a two-person song, kind of hard to sing.
Some of these songs are two-person songs.
Hard to sing, hard to sing.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Love the fast wiggles.
Hmm.
Hi, Minky.
Hello!
Oh, under 17?
She's speaking my language.
Wait.
Is it time for old songs now?
Under...
There we go.
Throwback time?
Is it time for old people songs?
Mouse to mouse!
Did anybody ever watch mouse?
The mouse...
The mouse anime about like the thief guy?
Do I even remember how Popotang goes?
Mouse, Jule Mouse.
Yes?
Really?
No way.
I'm trying to remember how Popotan goes.
It's on my MP3 player.
Saw that anime on Crackle.
What the heck is... You have it on DVD!
What the heck is Crackle?
I'll try Popo Tan Oh, I think I saw the lyrics and I was
like Wait, I think it's coming back to me I think it's
coming back to me
I'm like
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
La, la, la, La, la,
Compatibule Kino Mico do Nico do Tata Cicicic, full-color
Nino
I want What does it mean?
It's so Me,
it's so Cicicin' Yeah,
it's a
Oh, this setlist is crazy.
What is this?
Wait, I want to see if they have any mosaic wave on here.
Oh my gosh, wouldn't it be crazy if they had burn on by 10
situ dot?
BXC?
Oh, wait.
Mosaic.
No,
they don't have any from my favorite album, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no,
that was easy.
Oh, I pressed the wrong button again.
Where did I go?
Where am I at?
I don't know.
Ham-Taro.
I love ham-Taro.
This is an easy song for me.
You're a- You're a- Daikida from Komogi.
Da-I-Ki-Dai- I was thinking that one actually.
I think they have it.
Any Udameishi somewhere on there?
We'll close out.
We'll close out with it.
Hi, say no My own toky Kasei Tami-chokyo Ja-ja, Baibo, Waipa
Kotoko, Hachiru-haimutaro Sumi-yiko, Hachiru-himutaro I love
Hi, say no Hii-mawari-no-tane I'm a boy, I'm a-himutaro
Tiger, Pioneer, Cyber, Piper,
Let's see.
Wait,
this is a...
Um, komugi, not the wrong komugi.
We have I know medicine.
Oh,
they don't have They don't have it Wait, maybe if I search
just a Momoi Haruko Might be under her Momoi Haruko Momoi
Haruko Haruko
Haruko Haruko Haruko, Haruko, Haruko, Haruko Wait, we could
sing Lavi XC
We could sing Love EXE.
That would be exciting.
What is already on?
Let's sing that one.
I think my...
Oh gosh, I think my controller is starting to die for real.
Oh my gosh.
The D-pad is broken, I think.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Sign into my Nintendo account again.
Why?
Okay.
I signed in.
That was weird.
Oh.
That was so strange.
Er.
Our 18 song needs verification.
Oh.
I wonder if an update screwed things up.
Oh, maybe.
You guys have to do the X-R-Z.
I carry this kind
I blame my body for my life.
Here's my life in this life Will say, Cheers A, new knowing
tomorrow A new day Now get ready to wake me up A new day
Here is the humble jubilant words I pray among the stars I
pray among the stars
One day I will do this song live I will teach you.
You guys will be pros.
Ready one more time!
Fix
and no Hacanae Hacanae Hacanae Hacanae Hacanae
Kakeinuke Secai
Sucinue Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
When you do the EXE, you throw your arms out, like praise
the sun, and then cross like X and then throw your arms back
out.
E, ku, ze, meh.
Pachi, pachi, pachi, pach, pach, pach, pach.
No, thank you so much for the pie.
Get there!
Thank you.
And then the claps that I'm doing.
Is, is, is.
Like, you clap and you jump around in a circle.
Hi, Minty!
It's the first time Supercharger live!
Thank you!
By the way, I'm surprised your pronunciation of Japanese is
supernatural.
Have a fun time with everyone.
Thank you!
What?
Eh?
Your name.
That name is...
Yeah, yeah, you praise the sun and then cross and then
praise the sun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So our heads in the middle is like the E.
Yeah, yeah, kind of, kind of, yeah, yeah.
We love your voice, thank you for the karaoke.
Miss, Miss, thank you!
Welcome back!
I didn't get Nihonko-Jozud.
I got...
Nihonko pronunciation.
Hatsuon jozu.
Hope you have a great time on your trip.
I'll miss you lots, but I can't wait to watch you in Skyline
Serenade!
Thanks for the wonderful singing today.
Thank you!
Yeah!
I'm not that good.
I'm not... I'm not... terrifying how good I am at karaoke.
I'm not... I'm not so good.
I just like to have fun.
Wait, we said today we would do...
Some... some...
Oh gosh, what's a musical?
Actually, I think I know what I want to sing.
Let's sing some musical songs.
I'll sing a couple of musical songs and then...
I'll sing this one first.
Oh gosh.
This one always makes me laugh.
I'm gonna have Seymour sing his own part though.
I'll sing Audrey.
Actually, I'll sing Seymour's part in the beginning.
And then I will sing Audrey.
Lift up your head.
Wash off your mascara.
Here, take my Kleenex.
Wipe that lipstick away.
Show me your face.
Clean as the morning.
I know things were bad, but now they're okay.
Suddenly Seymour is standing beside you.
Sorry, there's gonna be a man and the ending, okay guys,
it's Seymour, the part I'm singing right now.
He's gonna come in.
Don't have to pretend.
Suddenly Seymour is here to provide you with sweet
understanding.
Seymour's your friend, nobody's ever treated me kindly.
Daddy left early, Mama was poor.
I'd meet a man and I'd follow him blindly.
fingers for me I'd say sure Suddenly Seymour is standing
beside me He don't give me orders He don't condense it
Suddenly Seymour is here to provide me sweet understanding
Seymour's my friend tell me the bad times are clean washed
away please understand that it's still strange and
frightening for losers like I've been it's so hard to say
suddenly is Seymour he purified me suddenly a symbol showed
me I can learn how to be one the girl that's inside me what
sweet understanding what sweet understanding what Sweet
understanding was Sweet understanding
Seem was your man
Suddenly You know that's how we get into the musical part
Because it's just a suddenly Suddenly Seemore Suddenly
Seemore appears I wanted to see little shop while i was in
new york perfectly themed that's kind of also why i picked
it because little shop of horrors is playing right now at
broadway
suddenly seymour what's another that was insane was it oh
it's another musical oh seymour
yeah yeah Seymour from Final Fantasy Wait This is not Oh I
wanna sing Final Fantasy Oh wait I wanna sing Final Fantasy
See Suddenly Seymour
Oh I wanna sing Final Fantasy I wanna sing Um Oh, um...
This song, Error, sings in Rebirth.
Uh...
What, no promises to keep, is it?
Or...
I've been trying to learn it, but I haven't had time.
A thousand words!
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da
Do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do,
do, do, do, do, do, do, I remember that one?
The song is so Disney Princess Coded.
No Promises to Keep, it's so Disney Princess Coded.
Eyes on me?
I can do Eyes on Me.
I'll do a thousand words after.
I'll add it to the karaoke.
We'll just do a little short Final Fantasy break.
Whenever sang my songs, on the stage, on my own, whenever
said my words, wishing they would be heard.
I saw you smiling at me.
or just my fantasy You'd always be there in the corner of
this tiny little bar My last night here for you Same old
songs, just once more My last night here with you Maybe yes,
maybe no.
I kind of liked it your way, how you shyly placed your eyes
on me.
And did you ever know that I had mine on you?
Darling, so there you are With that look on your face As if
you're never heard As if you're never down Shall I be the
one for you Who pinches you so far But sure, if round is
shown then I will know that you are no dreamer
So let me come to you Close as I wanna be enough for me to
feel your heart beating fast and stay there as I whisper how
I loved your peaceful eyes on me did you ever know that I
had mine on you Darling, so share with me your love if you
have enough.
Your tears if you're holding back your pain if that's what
it is.
The dress and the voice.
Just reach me out then.
You will know that you are not dreaming Darling, so there
you are With that look on you're
As if you're never As if you're never Shall I be the one for
you Who pinches you softly But sure, if brown is shown, then
I will know that you are no dreamer.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, Kari's so quiet.
Thank you so much for the act, guys.
How bad!
I'm safe to be at the live concert, unfortunately, work.
I'll be so happy watching the concert stream.
I'm so happy to be haunted by this ghost.
Thank you so much for the act, thank you so much.
Oh, thank you so much.
Oh, don't, oh, oh, oh, we just have it.
Oh, gosh.
Thank you.
Eyes on me.
I don't know if this, my voice will suit this one.
I know that you're hiding things.
Using gentle words to shelter me.
How does this go again?
Your words were like a dream.
But dreams could never fool me Not that easily I acted so
distant then Didn't say goodbye before you left But I was
listening You'll fight your battles far from me Far too
easily Save your tears because I'll come back I could hear
that you whispered as you walked through that door But still
I soar to hide the pain the pages shall they bite up in the
answer what if I find my eyes out have begged you not to
depart but now I'm not afraid to say what's in my heart cuz
a thousand words all out through the ages the to you even
though I can't see I know they're reaching you suspended on
silver wings oh a thousand words 1,000 embraces will cradle
you making all of your weary days seem far away they'll hold
you for a
oh a
thousand words i've never been spoken they'll fly to you
they'll carry you home and back into my arms suspended on
silver wings and a thousand words fall out through the ages
They'll cradle you Making all of the lonely years See you
only days Only days They'll hold you forever
A thousand words Oh
Please!
Oh my god!
Sorry!
I forgot part of the song, but then I also forgot!
It makes me sad!
Makes me so sad!
No!
It's so good to see you.
Yo, kata!
Uh oh, my tab just crashed.
One second.
Making me cry every time.
So good.
Oh, man.
Going from hype songs to pure sadness.
Your range is incredibly beautiful.
Do you have any tricks for swapping between head and chest
voice?
I had some advice because I don't know.
I need to go back to... Actually, my technique is probably
so bad.
I need to go back to singing lessons for a video.
I really like that song.
Thank you, Vito.
Sorry, Nexia.
I butchered it a little bit.
We can sing this one next.
Oh
It's a beautiful, soft, And it's a beautiful, It's so
beautiful, If you took your hands Take it to the world I
want to see you In the city of the city, In the handkerchief
In the heart In
the heart Aske
Yoying me Magir The
wind The wind is a mighty, the word is a a a a is a a a
long a a a a The sky is the blue, the sky is blue.
The
stars are so bright and it's pouring out.
The darkest, dark and darkly darkly.
It's a great day If you took your hand Take it all the way I
want to go I want to go
Oh, man.
Let's sing three more songs.
We'll go to 20.
2020 a musical a musical hmm a musical a musical oh my gosh
I saw a video earlier I was I was crying I saw a video
earlier of this of this wedding and they were singing one
more day and then her husband joined in and he was like
today's the day I fight with you and I was bawling earlier.
Oh my gosh, I love One More Day from Le Mez.
It's an in-between for sad song.
How about the silly Mickey Mouse?
No, no, no, it's okay.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
Wait, do they have one more day?
One more day.
That's like a...
Oh, they took it down.
No!
The song you're trying to play is not available.
Copyright owners do not authorize.
No!
It's fine because that song is literally meant for like 50
people so It's so oh my gosh that song just makes me Makes
me cry so much though
A musical, a musical, a musical You know I've never seen
Hamilton I do not know any songs from Hamilton unfortunately
Gimme Gimme Wait, what's that one Don't cry, streamer,
great, VTuber, Minto is streaming.
Watch her and you will feel better.
Sing all the counter melodies as a single person up for
real.
Wicked.
I do love singing me some wicked.
Um.
Wicked.
Which song, though?
Phantom?
Oh, I want to sing Phantom.
I could do popular I could do popular Wait, I feel like I
did popular last time We'll do Defying Gravity We'll do
something upbeat I can't sing this song well at all But, you
know, it's fine Elva, but why couldn't you have stayed calm
once Instead of flying off the handle I hope you're happy I
hope you're happy now How you hurt your cause forever.
Hope you think you're clever.
I hope you're happy.
Hey, this one.
I hope you're happy too.
I hope you're proud.
How you will travel in submission To feed your own ambition.
So though I can't imagine how...
Oops, we're saying the same.
I hope you're happy...
Right now.
Elfie, listen to me.
Just say you're sorry You can still be with the wizard What
you've worked and waited for You can have all you ever
wanted I know But I don't want it No I can't want it anymore
Something has changed within me Something is not the same
I'm through with playing by The rules of someone else's game
Too late for second guessing too late to go back to sleep.
It's time to trust my instincts, close my eyes, and leave.
It's time to try defying gravity.
I think I'll try defying gravity, and you can't pull me
down.
Can't I make you understand You're having delusions of
grandeur I'm through accepting limits Cause someone says
they're so Some things I cannot change But till I try I'll
never know Too long I've been afraid of Losing love I guess
I'm lost Well if that's love It comes at much too high a
cost I'm too nearby To find Gravity Kiss me goodbye I'm
defying gravity And you can't pull me down I boom Come with
me Think of what we could do Together Unlimited Together
we're unlimited Together we'll be the greatest team there's
ever been.
I blew the dreams the way we planned them.
If we work in tandem, there's no fight we cannot win.
Just you and I defying gravity.
When you and I...
Oh, shoot, I keep getting the right.
Wrong?
Harmony wrong.
They'll never bring us down.
I keep forgetting which is all about, which is Glinda Gr-
Are you coming?
I boo!
Which are their harmonies.
I hope you're happy now that you've chosen this.
You too.
I hope it brings you bliss.
I really hope you get it and you don't live to regret it.
I hope you're happy in the end Oh shoot I hope you're happy
My friend
So if you care to find me We'll look to the western sky told
me lately everyone deserves a chance to fly and if I'm
flying solo at least I'm flying free to those groups around
me take a message back from me tell them how I am defying
gravity I'm flying I am defying gravity I'll match them in
green now.
And nobody in all of us, no wizard that there is or was is
ever gonna bring me down.
Bring me down.
I'm getting to the end of my ropes here, guys.
I'm getting to the end of my ropes here.
That was defying gravity.
Let's sing some Phantom of the Opera.
Phantom of the Opera.
is there which one though oh so amazing you're going to be
the official comic kit merch i know hope you're able to grab
a lot to go hard of goods have a great time in new yorkers
always really thank you i can't believe oh my god i'm gonna
walk around comic kit i'm gonna see my face i'm shaking for
real right now holy cow music of the night i could do that
one wait what's what's wait all about all I ask of you hold
on I'm gonna listen to both of them I don't remember which
with this one is no more talk of darkness forget these
white-eyed feet I like this one sorry I have to sing with
this guy though
no more talk of darkness for I'm here nothing can harm you
My words will warm and calm you.
Let me know.
You got Raul's part?
Thank you, Raul.
Let daylight dry your tears.
I'm here with you beside you.
To catch you and to guide you.
Say you all love me.
Every waking moment Turn my head with talk of summertime.
Say, oh, meet me with you now and always.
Promise me that all you say is true.
That's all I ask of you.
Let me be your shelter, let me be your light.
You're safe, no one will find you.
Your fears are far behind you.
All I want is freedom, a world with no more light.
And you, always beside me, to hold me and to hide me.
Say you'll share with me one love, one lifetime.
Let me lead you from your solitude.
Say you'll need me with you here, beside you.
Anywhere you go, let me.
Are you guys Raul and I'm Christine?
That's all I have is coming.
Say you'll share with me one love, one lifetime.
Say the word and I will follow you.
Shall each day with me, each night, each morning, saying,
Love me, love I do, love me, that's all I ask of you.
Oh no, can I get this high note?
Oh gosh, hold on.
Maybe.
Oh gosh, it might be kind of hard for me though.
Can you hear your girl?
Let me go too.
Love me.
That's all I ask.
Oh.
Woof.
Yay!
That was all I ask of you from Phantom of the Opera.
All I ask.
Oh!
You nailed that part.
I mean, it's the singing, man.
See, that's right there why you're the best boss.
The one and only.
No, no, no.
Typically, I play tree number three.
There we go.
Thank you for the roses.
Watch Digital Canary, thank you for the August, Opaa!
Thank you for the August, Opaa!
Oh my goodness, oh my goodness!
Well, guys, we have one last song.
One last summer song until I send you off a wave.
And I will see you guys in about a week-ish, a week and a
half-ish.
Thank you so much, Amito, of course.
Yes.
One last summer song.
to end the summer.
Minky.
I'm sure you guys have some VODs to catch up on.
You won't miss me for that long.
I'll be gone and back before you know it.
Missed out my favorite Sankey Ghoul, so I'll be live for a
while, but you are in this vacation.
Please enjoy every moment of it.
I'll be catching up on VODs in the meantime.
Yes.
From the bottom of my baby eye, blue heart.
Thank you.
No, thank you.
Blue Cherry.
Thank you.
like I ever forget but even still you always find a way to
surprise me with how amazing Oh my gosh Weebo Danger I have
your flowers that you made for me in a vase with a little
napling I sent a picture of it to Nimi yesterday Thank you
Thank you Thank you Beautiful performance Have you ever seen
The Phantom sequel?
Sequel?
No, I haven't.
I'm really glad.
Yes, thank you.
I'll take a picture and I'll post it sometime.
It's really cute.
It's really, really cute, I think.
Dorigo, thank you so much for the awkward dodo.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for the beautiful karaoke, Min-do.
You're incredible, and congrats to get on the C-108.
Amazingness.
We'll miss you so much while you're gone, but hope you have
the absolute best time ever.
See you next week in NYC.
See you next week!
He's not aware of your gamest mint.
Thank you for the beautiful songs.
Thank you!
Strikes, thank you.
You're singing to some beautiful minto.
Thank you for blessing us today.
Ah!
Minky, minky, minky, minky, minky, minky, minky, minky.
This word thank you!
You were giving some amazing performances.
Oh, sorry, not amazing.
Insane.
Insane performances today.
Thank you.
Holy cow.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I thought I wasn't doing so good today because I kept
singing up the songs.
Oops.
But thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
That performance left me genuinely speechless.
No way.
Thank you very much.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate you guys.
I'm glad you guys like my...
My...
I'm getting sleepy and hungry.
My singing.
Okay.
Last song is my original song.
My newest original song.
Gudamishi summer.
Wait, is this a...
Hold on, let me make sure it's...
Uh, wait.
I gotta find the karaoke.
Wait, okay, here we go.
Gudamishi.
Okay.
Wait, actually...
Yeah, this is fine.
Is this it?
Wait, hold on.
Instrumental, there we go.
Okay.
My original song!
And then I will see you guys later.
I was all on karaoke today, so...
When are you gonna do a full album?
I don't know.
I always feel like I'm...
I know you guys are like, you're giving a great performance
tonight, but I always feel like my singing is not strong
enough for a solo album.
But I would love to do an album with Denzetsu.
I'd love to do an album with Denzetsu sometime.
I think this song is also perfect for the Ferris wheel.
Oh,
wait, I just realized you guys can't hear it.
There we go.
Thank you.
That's the end of the year
And during the summer And the rest of the year She's going
to end.
I'm Ture Museum That's stuff, I'm guessing That's how I know
that summer It's going to be repeated It's, I'm
guessing, I'm guessing
Yay!
Udame shi- Udame shi- Udame shi- Udame shi- Udame shi- Udame
shi- Udame shi- Udame shi- Wait, hold on I lost, there it
is, the set list Yay!
Actually, I know some people have been wondering when this
will be on streaming Actually Actually Kaseki Sider the
composer of the song wanted me to go and record in his own
studio to make a different oh my gosh it scared me a
different streaming version so sometime this year I will be
sorry it will delay the streaming version a little bit for a
while probably but I will be flying back to Japan and
recording that not this trip but probably the next one so
yeah thank you so much for the amazing karaoke, Minto!
Thank you, thank you!
You're one of the most beautiful singing voices I've ever
heard.
Oh, no, no, no.
Thank you so much, though.
Hi, robot.
Thank you so much for the pink, dono.
Thank you, thank you, too.
Always, thank you always for the amazing music, Minky.
Thank you!
Properly doing my little swimming stroke foodie copy.
Yes!
Jordan, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Safe travels, Minto.
Hope you have a great time at Comic Kit.
So excited for Skyline Serenade.
Me too!
Thank you guys for karaoke today!
It was so fun!
I hope you guys had fun.
What a set list, wow.
Craziness.
We went from sabotage to a thousand words all over the
place.
I tried to keep it summery, but in the end it became
whatever I felt like.
So that's fine.
Huge congrats on everything, boss.
Please enjoy your trip and actually take a break this time.
I will try.
for kiyuki tonight man see you skyline next week see you
hope you have a blast in japan and i come again thank you so
much thank you guys have a great trip thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you
too i mean thank you shadow cross zero thank you for the
rose brick thank you thank you so much welcome back welcome
back safe travels to you thank you oh to meet though
everybody oh to meet though i'm getting so hungry i'm
getting starved actually so If anybody is having a delicious
dinner, let me know.
I will head on over.
Safe travels.
Thank you for spoiling us with your singing.
I feel like you guys need earplugs for it.
Thanks for the rose.
Kaafune.
Oh, Kaafune.
I was thinking of singing some Kaafune songs today.
Heck it.
But I decided I want to learn it more properly.
So I'll learn it.
Safe travels.
Thank you.
Have a great trip, Minto.
Thank you, thank you.
Super liminal, thank you.
What's up, everybody?
What's up, Miao?
Miao, Miao, Miao.
Played this song in the car on the way to store.
Mom enjoyed it and sang with the cue.
I'm so happy to
miss you.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Koi, more loop.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Be-bye-bye.